esto es lo que queda de esta escuela
secundaria situada en la capital de la
provincia de helmand después de que
fuera alcanzada por los ataques aéreos
de las fuerzas gubernamentales afganas
que luchan por recuperar el control de
las cargas una localidad ahora en manos
de los talibanes
el ataque aéreo se produjo alrededor de
las diez y media de la noche los
guardias me llamaron y me dijeron que la
escuela se había incendiado que fuera
hallada en
una clínica cercana también quedó
reducida a escombros por el ataque los
bombardeos aéreos tuvieron como objetivo
posiciones talibanes matando a 50
combatientes islamistas y dejando
decenas de heridos mientras tanto los
funcionarios dicen que hubo al menos un
civil muerto estos fundamentalistas
siguen ganando terreno en el país este
domingo capturaron tres urbes entre
ellas la importante ciudad de kunduz
capital de la provincia con el mismo
nombre que cayó tras los enfrentamientos
entre los talibanes y las fuerzas de
seguridad afganas horas más tarde las
ciudades de share pool ita local
quedaron en manos de los combatientes
este es el último golpe para las fuerzas
de seguridad que ya habían perdido mucho
terreno en los últimos días desde el
viernes otras dos capitales de provincia
caído en manos talibanes se ve genial
sand izarán capital de la provincia de
ninh rose gran parte del campo ha caído
en manos del grupo islamista desde mayo
cuando las tropas extranjeras se fueron
haciendo en sucina que la retirada de
sus fuerzas fue la decisión correcta
después de 20 años de conflicto la
apatía de eeuu se completará justo antes
del aniversario número 20 de los
atentados del 11 de septiembre